there is more bad news for Florida
Republican Governor Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis as he is on his Asia tour while
there is a flooding recovery happening
in Florida that includes long gas lines
the santises in Asia like a bobble head
as we saw earlier this week and he is
now getting sued by Disney World I have
been saying for weeks
Rhonda santis is over playing his hand
with the anti-woke stuff and Ron
DeSantis is really overplaying his hand
with the anti-disney stuff and if you
think Dominion voting systems had good
attorneys representing them against Fox
News just wait until you see how good
Disney's attorneys are CNBC reports
Disney Sue's Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis alleges political effort to
hurt its business Walt Disney company
sued Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
alleging that the Republican Governor
has waged a quote Relentless campaign to
weaponize government power over the
company you know Republicans love to use
the word weaponize and in fact they are
holding they have been holding hearing
since taking over the House of
Representatives
about the weaponization of government
and the weaponization of big Tech and of
course the terms are completely and
wholly inappropriate in those instances
if we are to accurately and correctly
use the term weaponization it's hard to
think of a better example than what Ron
DeSantis has done with government power
against Walt Disney World as a
retaliatory action for Walt Disney World
saying we're against the don't say gay
Bill the article continues the suit
dramatically escalates the feud between
DeSantis who's expected to become a top
Republican contender in the 2024
presidential race and Disney the lawsuit
was filed the same day that a
desantis-backed board moved to undo a
development deal that it says Disney
struck to thwart its power this is going
to be
a wild ride
and we've been talking about how Trump's
existing indictment and possible future
indictments might interfere with his
presidential primary campaign DeSantis
hasn't even announced that he's running
yet we don't know if he will
increasingly the polling is shaky or
shakier and shakier but if he did is it
possible that the chaos in Florida will
become a distraction and an impediment
Disney's attorneys in all likelihood
have had drafts of this lawsuit ready to
go
since quite early on in this entire
Fiasco and as Ron DeSantis kept finding
new ways to yes weaponize Florida
government against Disney
they continued to add to those lawsuit
drafts they were waiting for the board
to vote and now that the board has voted
they are suing now I want to be really
clear because I know some of you are
going to write to me and say David it's
weird to see a progressive gleeful about
the Uber capitalist Corporation Walt
Disney World
folks this this is not about that I I
don't like Disney I I mean I've said
before I hate theme parks when I went to
Disney World it was just horrifying it
overpriced ridiculously overpriced
terrible food long lines and it I hate
all of it okay Walt Disney was an
anti-semite just disgust like I don't
like anything about Disney but if I step
back and look at the facts DeSantis is
in the wrong here from everything that
has been publicly reported obviously at
some point when we say well is he in the
wrong there has to be an adjudication we
have a lawsuit here and we may have a
version of that adjudication and this is
a crusade that I have been telling you
for a while really May backfire and even
though I don't like so there's the
socio-cultural part and then there's the
legal part on the socio-cultural part I
recognize that just because I can't
stand Disney World doesn't mean that
tens of millions hundreds of millions of
people absolutely love it and picking a
fight with Disney is potentially a
losing battle just at its face that's
number one and then number two as we've
said before
um aside from Disney specifically
the country for the most part is on the
woke side not the anti-woke side and you
know the don't say gay bill was a big
part of the Disney controversy with Ron
DeSantis we had a recent poll which
asked Americans on the whole do you
think that Society has done too much not
enough or about the right amount when it
comes to protecting and whatever LGBT
folks and the balance was on we've done
the right amount or not enough in other
words the majority of the country
doesn't think that woke is going too far
or whatever phraseology the right wants
to apply to it so we'll see about the
legal aspect of it
um certainly when it comes to the
socio-cultural in all sorts of different
ways Ron DeSantis seems to have
dramatically overstepped here we will
watch it but this is a crusade that may
well backfire
the weather is about to start warming up
and that often means sweating and
chafing and sticking sheath is the men's
underwear that once and for all puts an
end to all of that nonsense our sponsor
sheath underwear has designed unique
boxer briefs with an ergonomic
compartment built to keep everything
separate and dry and cool and
comfortable by allowing air to circulate
everywhere it needs to be no more
readjusting all day sheath offers a huge
variety of designs and patterns over
half a million pairs have already been
sold also check out their super
comfortable bamboo t-shirts sheath has
amazing customer service super fast
shipping along with over twenty thousand
five star reviews sheath is also
actively working with multiple
non-profits that deal with mental health
and homelessness which you support when
you get sheath underwear I've had a
great experience with sheath underwear I
know you will too head on over to
sheathunderwear.com Pacman and use the
code Pacman for 20 off the link is down
below